je suis presque sûr que vous avez tous
vu ces vidéos de daltoniens qui voit les
vraies couleurs pour la première fois
j'ai pu en avoir une paire
[Musique]
l'athlète dernière on a vu ce que tu
étais être daltonien
et je vous ai dit que j'étais moi-même
daltonien donc avant de commencer on va
vérifier sans trois je suis pas sûr pas
sûr je suis pas sûr
là c'est un roman l'onu non voilà donc
apparemment je suis strong de thann
c'est à dire 2 terranum balèze ça va
vous inquiétez pas j'étais déjà au
courant donc tout va bien je confond le
vert et le marron le vert et le rouge et
parfois le piolet et le bleu et puis un
certain nombre d'autres nuances
voilà mais rien de méchant et donc je
suis presque sûr que vous avez tous vu
ces vidéos de daltoniens qui voit les
vraies couleurs pour la première fois
[Musique]
magnifique c'est tellement bon moi
j'avais jamais essayer donc j'ai eu
envie de tester ces fameuses lunettes
correctrices et grâce à l'ami squeeze
qui les a lui même testé parce qu'il est
aussi daltoniens et qu'il a fait une
vidéo sur le sujet j'ai pu en avoir une
paire merci en vérité je les ai déjà
avec moi depuis un certain temps mais
pour pas gâcher la surprise est vraiment
pour découvrir le truc en même temps que
vous je ne les ai pas essayer alors
c'est parti pour un homme boxes
alors voilà la bête ça se présente sous
forme d'une boîte petit instruction et
voilà le précieux des tuyaux oui je vous
ment pas elle sont encore sous blister
à première vue comme ça ça ressemble à
des lunettes de soleil classique on
essaye à avant voilà
ok donc pour l'instant rien de spécial
[Musique]
je déconne c'est sévère mais c'était
déjà des arabes ont effectivement alors
c'est assez bizarre sur les côtés ça n'a
pas tout à fait la même couleur qu'au
milieu c'est sombre sermon le sombre un
peu plus clair au milieu à l'est par
contre j'ai pas du tout la même couleur
de mes mains ont une couleur bizarre
est-ce que je suis rouge je vois
clairement pas ma peau de la même
couleur que d'habitude paraît qu'il faut
dix quinze minutes pour s'y faire et en
plus c'est des lunettes qui sont faites
pour fonctionner à l'extérieur par
évidemment la question que je me pose
moi c'est comment est ce que ça marche
alors j'ai été voir sur le site de la
marque qui commercialise les lunettes
avec en chrome à nos placements produits
parce que bon je n'ai pas été payé le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que il n'y
a pas des masses d'informations sur
vraiment la technologie ans vont nous
explique que les verres des lunettes
diminue certaine longueur d'onde
celle qu'on voit plutôt bien pour rendre
celle que d'habitude on voit pas bien
plus visibles explique aussi que ça
diminue le chevauchement des courbes
rouges et vertes sont même fait un petit
juif
ça m'a pas convaincu convaincu en fait
tu comprends pas comment des lunettes
peuvent remplacer quelque chose qui
manque dans mes yeux et comment ça peut
leur permettre de voir quelque chose qui
sont pas équipés pour voir et les
explications que j'ai là me rende pas
optimiste optimiste et encore une fois
on va aller faire un petit tour dehors
on va tester et on verra bien alors ça
change quand même bien les couleurs d
habitude mais par contre pas du coup je
sais pas si c'est les bonnes là par
terre c'est un peu bleuté les pierres ou
pas mais gris gris bleu qua non je me
vois bien équipé
incroyable cette plante est verte elle
est tellement verte
voilà aussi
alors c'est marrant parce que je disais
tout à l'heure que je confondais le bleu
et le violet l'a vraisemblablement le
ciel est bleu et d'habitude je le voie
bleue parce que je ne me pose pas trop
de questions mais avec les lunettes je
le vois presque un peu violet en fait
est là du coup c'est rose et violet on
est d'accord là je les vois clairement
clairement beaucoup mieux avec les
lunettes que que sont surtout surtout le
rose en fait en petite anecdote amusante
un jour j'ai acheté une voiture bleue on
m'a avoué forme a annoncé au bout de six
mois qu'en fait elle était violette jeu
vraiment j'en étais pas rendu compte que
j'étais persuadé d'avoir une voiture
bleue et j'avais une voiture violer le
feu du haut ou bas il est bien rouge
mais pas différent de ouf de d'habitude
mais moi mon problème c'est le vert donc
on va attendre qu'il passe au vert
à
car apparemment ça fait des trucs sur
les bleus et sur les roses mais sur le
vert et le rouge pour l'instant c'est
pas fou alors là par exemple
bon bah ça avec les lunettes je dirais
gris anthracite et sans les lunettes je
dirais verts clairement vers adéquat à
les bleus est les bulls n'ont tu ta
gueule allez quoi as tu dis sur le site
aussi c'est que dix quinze minutes c'est
le temps qu'il faut pour que ça commence
à agir que plus tu les portes plutôt
oeil s'habitue plus c'est efficace
tu les portes dans la même journée et
plus tu les portent souvent c'est à dire
que logiquement pour que vraiment j'ai
un effet optimal
quoi qu'il dise faut le porter une
dizaine d'heures sur sur une semaine je
vais pas les garder 10 heures le ciel a
quand même une couleur particulière
le ciel est clairement violé sa effet ça
me permet de voir le gris gris par
contre je vois le bleu violet c'est
mitigé rouge à bâle alors c'est drôle là
je les vois marron clairement et la
gelée vote là je joue à je vois ça
orange avec les lunettes
et je vois jaune où sont les lunettes
ces zones alors on a pas mal de trucs on
va regarder ça sur l'aspirateur c'est
assez flagrant
le changement de couleur il est très
très saturé vin très vif et là il est
très pâle par contre là je le vois
marron et là je le vois rouge rouge rose
et du coup je sais pas si c'est le
changement de luminosité ou si c'est que
mes yeux s'habituent mais je me vois
plus rouge
moi je ne me vois plus heureux tu me
vois marron maintenant enfin légèrement
hâlé quoi envoyer en vacances la halle
en scène john comme ça orange comme ça
donc sur le jaune est sûre laurent
chalard de marche pas mal sur le marron
et le rouge ça a l'air de marcher pas
mal le gris et le vert ça a marché une
fois sur deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est chelou de regarder les mecs passer
dans la rue en soulevant ses lunettes
tee shirt rose ou pas rouge
rouge fuchsia renverser définitivement
romain à vendre des couleurs alors on
est pas mal assurée entre l'école de
code un truc là-bas la laisser en rouge
il est d en bleu ouais peut-être le haut
en verre et le riz oeufs en orange
[ __ ] là le scooter je vais vraiment
très rose ou bien rose bonbon avec les
lunettes et sans les lunettes
j'hésiterais vraiment entre
gris très clair
rose très pâle alors que là vraiment ça
peut être bon ça tu vas voir
après l'opus
tu peux pas
parce que c'est vert
j'avais pas vu mais c'est pas mal en
fait en fait un petit côté horatio caine
je crois qu'on est moins que les
lunettes sont pas faites pour faire le
test dit chara mais j'ai quand même
envie d'essayer parce que je vois pas
pourquoi je pourrais voir dehors et pas
et pas sur cet écran on va quand même
tester pendant 6 à change quelque chose
[Musique]
ah ben je suis passé de strong de thann
à modéré de thann donc peut-être qu'il
se passe quelque chose quand même
bon alors bilan est ce que ça marche
j'ai envie de dire oui et non 1
vous avez vu pour certaines couleurs ça
marche mais pas à tous les coups pour
d'autres couleurs
ça marche pas tellement et ça va même
parfois induit en erreur donc bilan
mitigé globalement quand même ça m'a
permis de voir des choses que je vois
d'habitude ça modifie ma vision des
couleurs elles sont plus saturés plus
vives havrais comme on en a parlé dans
la vidéo précédente
moi j'ai aucun moyen comparer ça avec
les vraies couleurs donc je ne sais pas
si le vert que j'ai vu qui est différent
de celui que je vois d'habitude il est
plus proche du vrai vers celui que vous
voyez si vous avez une vision normale
que le mien je ne sais pas ce qui est
assez clair c'est que ces lunettes
elles ont l'air de fonctionner dans la
mesure où ça te permet de voir des
choses que tu ne voit pas d'habitude en
tant que daltonien mais ça ne transforme
pas ta vision de daltoniens en vision
des couleurs normal non c'est pas un
miracle ce qui est sûr aussi c'est que
ça coûte entre 300 et 400 30 dollars
donc peut-être réfléchir un petit peu
avant d'en acheter
moi je sais ça fait comme vous voulez
mais vous viendrez pas dire que je vous
ai pas prévenu à la dtcc fournit pour
aujourd'hui que vous avez envie que je
teste d'autres trucs
dites moi ça dans les commentaires je
sens que je vais regretter d'avoir dit
ça on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo d'ici là mettez vous bien
et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]